another thing that I'm going to bring up
is the notion of uh
gaslighting um there's a guy that
dropped this here okay so I'm going to
read you the
story they say that when you point your
finger at somebody there's always three
pointing back so this is a interesting
story a warning maybe I don't
know let me put it up on the screen for
you uh nope yep there it
is so this guy left this comment on the
community tab of the entrepreneurs and
cars page I'll just read it to you he
says I dated this one woman in my early
20s absolutely fell in love with her on
the fourth year of dating she started
accusing me of cheating it was very
stressful because I wasn't how many of
you guys have dated a chick and she
started accusing you of cheating
pointing the finger at you remember when
somebody does this there's three fingers
pointing back at them
okay it was stressful because I wasn't
if if you're not doing anything and
she's accusing you of doing something I
would start digging through some
and getting ready to untie this
relationship just
saying she then broke up by text that's
when I learned what heartbreak was it's
an awful feeling when you go there the
first time I'm going to explain why
women get over heartbreak a lot faster
than men to after I read this anyways
come to find out the months after one of
her female friends who liked me started
telling me everything that was going on
with my ex the interesting thing about
evidence I learned this in a lawsuit one
one of the first lawsuits that I got
involved with that I had to deal with uh
I don't know 20 years ago maybe or
something like that my lawyer said at
the time evidence always has to find a
way always finds a way of coming to you
for the most part evidence always finds
a way of coming to you so if anybody's
everever crossed you pissed down your
back and told you it's raining the
evidence will probably come your way you
generally don't have to go looking for
it this is what happened to this
guy uh female friends who like me
started telling me everything apparent
apparently she had started seeing some
other guy a month before dumping me
shocking right for context he was older
and had more money than me at the time
shocking right monkey branch is up to a
better guy this is the Betrayal that
women do she deceives this guy for it
says a month it could have been longer
she deceives this guy for a period of
time while she's checking out the other
guy that she's trying to Monkey Branch
to that's more influential that's
richer again betrayal cheating very
different things
uh started telling me everything was
going so she's obviously seeing this guy
they're dating they're going out you
know they're forming a romantic Bond
again women form these bonds men don't
need to that's that's why men can spin
plates and they don't have any emotional
attachment issues whereas when women do
it they have huge issues with it
right everything apparently she started
seeing some other guy D but the guy was
actually married with a kid my ex didn't
know the wife of the guy came to my ex's
place she still lived with her mother
and confronted her about 3 weeks passed
by and the ex calls me thinking that she
does that he doesn't know what happened
she tried to get back with me I'm not
going to lie I did Smash a couple times
but realized I wasn't looking for a
relationship after that she asked me
what are we I started laughting and said
I don't know friends she said friends
don't bang I said I don't know what do
you want me to tell you we were together
once as a couple and couples don't bang
outside of the relationship that's why
you cannot forgive a woman if she steps
out on you you just can't she formed a
bond with a guy that she thought was
better than you and now she wants to
come back and
reconcile have some dignity
man I started laughing okay started
crying I honestly felt bad in my mind I
couldn't understand how she thought we
were going to go back to relationship
after what she did this is the this is
the mental retardation okay like this is
this is the level of delusion that women
operate within is they think that they
can go and cheat on you with a married
dude like she didn't know right cheat on
you with a married dude that doesn't
work out and then try to come back to
you and be like I'm really sorry you
know I think I made a mistake I'd like
to come back to you not knowing what it
is that she did right I thought she knew
she stopped talking sorry so I stopped
talking to her as much as I could then
her friend started to call me to get
back with her I told them that she did
she did some did I told them what she
did some didn't know okay I finally seen
her one last time where she was looking
for a relationship and I said okay
that's cool best of luck she said she
wanted to be with me I said I couldn't
do that in the future appreciate the
person that loves her blah blah blah
okay apparently she didn't learn that
because a couple years later she called
me from an unknown number late at night
saying she was going to get married but
if there's a chance between me and her
she would take it oh my
God what up 304 garden tools right
saying she was going to get married
there's a chance between see women do
this routinely they routinely do
this there's a notion in bachette Pary
is called the dancing bear look it up it
is not a myth it is not an urban legend
I had a mail stripper on one
time uh for a 90-minute podcast you can
you can dig through my podcast history
I'm sure you can find it and he did the
whole dancing bear routine and all that
really means is you go to a
bachelorette party where they're getting
ready for the wedding in the next few
days all the gals get together you know
you think that they're going to get
their nails done or some if there's
strippers there the dancing bear happens
and this is when the the stripper will
bang your fiance before she gets married
to you this is how women are this is how
nefarious things can get okay again I'm
only speaking from experiences people
that I've talked to people that have
shared this sort of information anyway
so this chick said that she's going to
get married if there's a chance uh she
would take it I told her no be happy
enjoy your rest of lives congratulations
I look back now and I dodge a massive
bullet these stories are everywhere guys
they're all over the Internet they're
all over the internet again when a woman
starts accusing you you should start
asking questions especially if you're
not doing anything really start asking
some
questions have you heard of the notion
of War Brides I talked about it in my
book guys if you haven't the unplugged
Alpha the second edition is available
it's a great holiday gift for family and
friends it really is the language has
been cleaned up and and still able to
deliver a strong message to wake people
up but the language has been cleaned up
so it's not as harsh for people that get
easily rubbed the wrong way by Cold
Heart truths they're still cold heart
truce they're just a little bit warmer
cold hard truths anyway the second
edition is out there so the notion of
War Brides is a phenomenon that's been
observed throughout history uh when
conquering armies Will Roll in they'll
acquire whatever they want the horse The
Oxen uh fighting you know material
they'll take the men and the boys of
fighting age and they'll put them either
in slavery or they'll kill them off the
women and the girls are preserved as War
Brides and they very very comfortably
move from their tribe let's just say
loar of the Hill People is running a
tribe with a 100 uh villagers on the
hill loar's
hill and the Romans come in doesn't
matter if it's a Romans if it's the
Vikings if it's the Greeks if it's the
Persians if it's the Ottomans doesn't
matter what Empire it was loar the Hill
People is now either dead or put in
slavery and so are his brothers his
cousins and his sons so what's left now
the women and the girls what do you
think the Waring Army did with all the
women and girls they made them their
brides and they had babies with them
right because women had value to them
right and what interestingly happened
was all of these women would warmly
embrace the conquerors which you think
is counterproductive and absolutely
crazy but it's happened over and over
again throughout history um as a
recently as World War II there's
accounts of French Dutch uh all of these
women as the German armies rolled into
their countries um the men went into
hiding because they were either going to
get killed or put into slavery camps uh
so they'd go in the sewers they' go and
hiding or whatever the men would
basically disappear and the women would
now Embrace their conquerors and they
would sleep with them and have children
with them one of the things that the
Dutch did I think it was a Dutch um
after World War II ended was they
marched all the women that betrayed the
Dutch people and was and were banging
the German soldiers they marched them
into the city squares and they shave
their heads to embarrass them right
because they behaved as War Brides so
the notion of War Brides exists and has
existed throughout history it didn't
even matter if it was you know 250,000
years ago go back a million years ago
and some random half monkey half human
evolving through you know history uh
dies when he's out hunting saber-tooth
tigers or mammoths or or giant Cave
Bears and doesn't come back well what do
you think you know his woman or women in
the tribe or the village had to do then
she had to find the next guy so she
would just monkey Branch over to the
next guy and forget about you know the
dude that got slaughtered by the
saber-tooth tiger you know quick enough
and that's why women can move on faster
than men men suffer like I man look I've
I've suffered I've seen lots of men
suffer I've heard women go it's so
painful and it hurts and you don't
understand no you don't understand what
men go through when they are betrayed by
a woman that they invest in their heart
their soul their blood their sweat and
their tears women will never understand
the sacrifices that men make for them
they just won't men don't expect them to
it's cool feature not a bug that's why
women survive that's why women you know
are able to move from dude to dude she's
widowed dude dies from her saber-tooth
tiger war and tribe doesn't matter what
happen you know whatever it happens to
be she's able to move on and move on
quickly women are very good at it
they're adapted to it men not so much we
would we would usually die or just
suffer like you know
essentially so that's why you see women
get over breakups a lot faster so as
hurt as they are and in their feelings
at the time that's right that's how they
feel they have no comprehension
whatsoever because they solipsism they
can't see the male experience I can see
both the male and the female experience
I don't know maybe with the exception of
Esther Perell I don't know any women
that I've seen speak on these matters
speak with the level of conviction and
empathy and understanding uh that exists
in in knowing the differences between
how men and women behave when it comes
to cheating and stepping out and
betrayal all on that sort of stuff so
again that's why women get over a lot
faster than men they they've just
adapted to like they had to they
couldn't sit there and sulk like a
little I've seen men I've seen men
take a year not sleeping properly curled
up in a little ball crying like a little
like hoping that things will come
back or they can find some way to
rekindle or whatever um it's it's it's
sad like it's it's it's sad it's
pathetic I've done it too um so I'm not
sitting there pointing fingers saying
you know it's just you guys we've all
done it you know we've all done it
especially when you're plugged in like
when you're plugged into comforting
lives and society's you know we
all do it I really hope you guys enjoy
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clip's from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out